Hey youtubers it’s Charlie and now that
Marvel is officially shopping a finished Inhumans
script around to directors I thought it was
time to do a video.
There have been all kinds of rumors about
Agents of SHIELD and Skye having Inhuman parents,
Vin Diesel teased fans that he might be part
of an Inhumans movie.
And Marvel is making making some Inhumans
roster changes on the Avengers soon.
Since this is my first Inhumans video I’ll
explain their backstory in the comics, and
then talk about what’s going on with the
project at Marvel.
I will do follow up bonus videos for my favorite
Inhumans characters and stories so be sure
to subscribe to get those.
If you haven’t heard about the Inhumans
they’re an offshoot of humanity created
millions of years ago by the Kree.
They experimented on humans during the Kree
Skrull War by exposing primitive homosapiens
to the Terrigen Mists.
The circumstances of why the Kree chose humans
to experiment on is a whole other really interesting
story I can talk about in another video.
But the Kree were trying to create a race
of mutants to use against the Skrulls and
at the same time find a way to further evolve
the Kree species.
The Terrigen Mist is a vapor created from
Terrigen Crystals.
The Crystals are extremely rare and occur
naturally inside the Earth’s moon.
After the Kree started using the mutagenic
properties of the mist on humans the city
of Attilan formed as a place for the new creations
to live.
The use of the mists is very controversial.
The process of terrigenesis, exposing a human
to the vapor can have very volatile results.
Sometimes a person can emerge hideously deformed.
So as the Kree started experimenting more,
they implemented a selective breeding program
to weed out the more negative mutations.
That’s why some of the Inhumans like Black
Bolt look normal and some like Gorgon, his
sister, have their appearance radically altered.
The mists do that, it’s a random thing that
happens when they’re exposed.
Not all Inhumans choose to expose themselves
to the mist, there are just normal non-powered
Inhumans living in Attlian.
Taking in the mists is like a rite of passage.
Like becoming a warrior in tribal cultures.
Originally they first appeared in the Fantastic
Four comics in 1965.
They were created by Stan Lee and Jack Kirby.
So when we finally see the movie you can bet
that Stan Lee will have a cameo.
They have a very rigid caste structure.
Once someone is exposed to the mists they
are assigned a place in the Inhumans’ society
in the city of Attilan.
They only have the one city.
Think of it like the ancient chinese imperial
city.
Where for most of history no one was allowed
in.
It was like a sacred self-contained city.
Attilan’s location has been moved a few
times and most recently it was cloaked above
the earth’s surface during the Infinity
Storyline last year.
The most famous Inhuman’s characters are
the Royal Family, remember, very traditional
caste structure.
Black Bolt is King, his wife is Medusa, then
the rest of their family is Crystal, Gorgon,
Karnak, Luna, Lockjaw and Triton.
Usually when you see the covers of their comics
it’s one of those characters.
Black Bolt is the character Vin Diesel is
rumored to be playing.
He was born as Blackagar Boltagon.
His parents were two of Attilan’s smartest
geneticists.
Remember, selective breeding.
They were the head of the ruling council.
Black Bolt was exposed to the terrigen mists
while he was still an embryo.
He ended up developing powers that went way
beyond what normal Inhumans develop.
His biggest power is the sonic scream.
That’s the one they show off the most, but
he also has the ability to manipulate energy.
The speech center of his brain produces an
unknown particle that allows him to create
mentally controlled phenomena.
The reason his scream is so powerful is because
the particle he produces interacts with his
speech creating massive distortions in space.
So it’s not really his voice that destroys
people, his vocal cords produce an energy
distortion, visually they just make it look
like a super powerful banshee wail.
But that’s not really what’s going on.
Thus he’s not the chatty character Deadpool
is.
The little fork apparatus on top of his head
helps him control his power.
He can use his power to fortify himself, he
can use it to fly and he can project it like
a strike.
There’s a bunch more cool stuff he can do.
Think of him as a cooler version of magneto
with the way he manipulates energy.
He along with the rest of the Royal family
have a certain amount of telepathy.
Because he can’t speak easily he usually
communicates his wishes to his wife Medusa
telepathically and she speaks as his translator.
Each Inhuman has vastly different powers.
Medusa as the name implies has very interesting
hair.
It has the tensile strength of steel and she
can control each strand of it independently.
She uses it to thrash people around or immobilize
them.
She can also throw heavy stuff around with
it when she’s anchored to the ground.
Triton has a lot of aquatic based powers,
Lockjaw is a dog who was exposed to the mists
and developed the ability to teleport.
He also has a lot of dog-related powers.
He can ingest an infinite amount of matter
of all kinds.
He has super smell and empathic abilities
that enable him to sense if people are in
trouble a long ways away.
Black Bolt has a mad Brother named Maximus,
as in crazy mad.
He’s like the Loki to Black Bolt’s Thor,
always plotting to overthrow him.
Maximus’ powers are mostly psonic.
As in mind control.
Right now at Marvel Studios Kevin Feige and
the powers that be are really open to doing
an Inhumans project.
They have a finished script that they’re
using to attract directors.
Once they find a director, that person will
probably re-write the script.
But because things are just getting going,
it’s likely that we won’t see an Inhumans
movie until 2017 or 2018.
As for Agents of SHIELD.
Skye was teased as an inhuman just because
of the connection to the Kree soldier in TAHITI
and her resistance to Kree blood.
That hasn’t been confirmed or anything,
but they just hired Kyle Maclachan to play
her father and he’s not going to be wearing
blue makeup.
Thus, I say Inhuman is a better theory.
Plus in the comics most recently, the inhumans
have been on earth.
It’s also possible that Marvel could revise
the backstories of Quicksilver and Scarlet
Witch and instead of mutants, make them Inhumans.
Just because of the copyright issue with Fox
and X-Men.
Vin Diesel teasing an Inhumans movie is also
a recent thing.
Here’s his quote:
When I first got the call from Kevin Feige,
he prefaced the call by saying ‘This is
the strangest character Marvel has ever attempted.’
He said ‘Don’t answer me now, but instead
of making the fans wait until 2017, there’s
something that would be a brilliant idea,
we think you could be the only person who
could bring the emotion to this very challenging
task.
Don’t answer me Vin, don’t answer me,
let me send over my conceptual art.
Fiege was talking about Groot when he said
not making fans wait till 2017.
But what’s the 2017 thing?
In an earlier interview, he said that he was
up for new IP, intellectual property in 2017.
So he wasn’t talking about Guardians.
Then he also posted this picture recently:
This was posted August 9th.
So he’s joking about Guardians, but he could
also be teasing Inhumans.
Vin Diesel is attractive to Marvel for a number
of reasons, he’s a great actor and he has
a very large personal audience.
He has one of the largest facebook pages in
the world.
82 Million fans.
No matter how big he is, Marvel would never
let him spoil anything, but they could allow
him to have some fun teasing ideas just because
the response he gets is so big and so immediate.
The next Inhumans videos I’m planning are
my favorite stories and my favorite characters.
So I’ll try to post those in the next couple
of days before I do more Doctor Who.
Be sure to subscribe to get everything.
I’ll also start doing some more Marvel Phase
3 videos too for the other movies like Doctor
Strange, Black Panther and Ant-Man.
In the meantime, click here to learn all about
Guardians of the Galaxy 2 and click here to
learn all about Avengers 2.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!